googles app engine hallo mein name ist
luca und ich zeige euch heute google in
minecraft dies ist eine map von barrett
engineer den eventuell bisher nur aus
den minecraft commands kennt wo er immer
richtig coole commands am start hatte
die wir vorgestellt haben jetzt hat er
sich allerdings an einnahmen minecraft
google map probiert ihr seht schon da
oben google in minecraft minecraft
creation by the light engine
hier vorne seht ihr die command blog
konstruktionen beziehungsweise die
ganzen redstone sachen da können wir
auch zu kalten scoreboard players zb
verstehe ich nicht und hier verstehe ich
auch nicht aber den hier der ideen
verstehe ich denen input verstehe ich
aber das ist nicht ach das sind diese
unsichtbaren coolen blöcke das soll
nicht hauptbestandteil des videos seien
sondern ich möchte euch natürlich zeigen
was man hier mitmachen kann und zwar
sehen wir hinter uns schon klick hier
tür open your keyboard das heißt wir
drücken wir drauf und wir sehen im chat
google app engine
hier haben wir zur tastatur die ist so
angeordnet wie eine normale tastatur
haben wir anders chor wir haben hier die
ganzen sachen via sd 0 bis 9 die zahlen
und hier unten research aim search pages
und rewrite das heißt ich zeige euch
erstmal was ist wenn ich beispielsweise
hier konnten traf der 1 gb und ihr seht
schon verdammt ich hab cjm chf 4 2 3 das
ist nicht mein name in der tat gelingt
ihr euch so scheiße ich habe mich
verschrieben
ja ihr könnt nicht einfach so sagen okay
zwei schritte zurück und da an
buchstaben löschen sondern ihr müsst auf
freeride klicken und dann müsst ihr
alles von vorne nochmal eingeben ist ein
bisschen umständlich wenn man was ganz
langes geschrieben hat allerdings geht
es nicht anders wir googeln jetzt mal
richtig konkreter das heißt cnc rtr
das ist doch nicht war als ob ich zwei
mal nix anstatt in c geschrieben hab ich
nicht denn behindert ist halt ein
bisschen umständlich weil man das ganze
nicht mit seiner eigenen tastatur machen
kann sondern man muss es mit diesem
kleinen dinge machen aber das steht
jetzt kontrast und jetzt können wir
erstmal auf search items klicken da seht
ihr jetzt 6 core of test vor player
kontrakt 38 das heißt wer mit alles
nachgeschaut hier irgendwelche items
gerade sind mit den namen von crafter
ist nicht der fall wenn wir theoretisch
auf search pages klicken sehen wir alles
mögliche was jetzt im internet dazu
angezeigt wird ist auch nichts von mir
geben mal was anderes an wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal google ein eventuell liegt
halt einfach daran dass sie kein
konkreter heißt und allgemein auch dass
die
er hat er keinen zugriff auf alles akuma
google.de inception google inception
keine ahnung was es soll natürlich ist
es jetzt kein richtiges google also es
ist jetzt nicht so wie die internet
motto ich dann auch mein auges richtig
angeschwollen irgendwie ich habe damals
mal internet motte minecraft
vorgestellte verlinke ich euch mal hier
oben falls ich nicht verkehrt das liegt
ja echt ekelhaft aus natürlich hat das
nicht zugriff auf die kompletten google
datenbanken ihr seht schon dann müsste
das ding nach 1000 jahre weiter nach
hinten gehen und es ist für eine map
einfach viel zu anspruchsvoll also wenn
ihr sehen wollt wie man alles minecraft
kann könnt euch das video anschauen was
hier oben dann irgendwie verlinkt ist
oder so aber hier kann man halt nur ein
paar sachen googeln ich könnte mal
schauen was ist denn rein theoretisch
also google haben wir jetzt nachgeschaut
was ist denn wenn ich einfach mal hier
freeride klick und ich gebe mal
minecraft auch nicht mu und noch ein
thema am ende der minecraft und wenn ich
search alterns besucher setzte auf
testfahrt player
ich hab keine ahnung was mit items sein
soll aber wenn wir aufs pages klicken
steht found minecraft dort mit da musste
doch eigentlich auch kontrapunkt tv
finden ich geh jetzt mal einfach den
namen vom web ersteller ein weil wenn er
es gemacht hat
red schon wieder verschrieben
so also wenn er ist halt gemacht habe
kann ich mir zumindest vorstellen dass
er sich selbst eingebracht hat das heißt
search items wie bekommen wir bekommen
seinen kopf ist also der kopf vom heck
vom macher viel ihr seht im index wenn
ich ins inventar von map maker says
das ist der kopf von der red engineer
crazy den haben wir gerade einfach
bekommen wenn jetzt rein theoretisch
search pages 1 gb steht found his
youtube ist minecraft forums planet
minecraft profit pro fall also so ein
paar profile von ihm aber jetzt würde
mich mal interessieren da wir jetzt
einen kopf bekommen haben was wäre denn
wenn ich einfach mal beispielsweise dort
ein geben würde würde dann dazu will ich
da so ein dirt altem einfach bekommen
oder was wird dann genau passieren und
es passiert nichts
pages klicken passiert ebenfalls nichts
also ich verstehe nicht ganz genau was
wir hiermit jetzt alles googeln kann ich
dachte man könnte mehr googeln aber also
das ist halt wirklich in der internet
funktion hätte weiß jetzt zweimal
getestet hatte das einzige was ich ein
gegeben hatte war mein name oder kam
nichts aber das kann ich mir schon
mitdenken können aber das enttäuscht
mich ein wenig dass da hier was das
sonntag so ich gebe jetzt mal gerade
hier o'brien ein eventuell bekomme ich
daher irgendein altem oder irgendwas in
der webpage aber es sieht auch sehr sehr
schlecht aus und was ist wenn ich einen
theoretisch mondschein gebe ich meine
das ist ein begriff wie minecraft ist
wie oder minecraft direkt mit deutschen
verbindung gebracht items nix pages
nichts ich habe keine ahnung bisher das
einzige was bekommen hatte war der map
maker google und minecraft das war's zu
mehr habe ich jetzt hier keine antwort
bekommen
ich weiß nicht was man noch was findet
ihr wenn ihr könnt ihr ja mal was suchen
da drin und dann in die kommentare
schreiben zu was man noch was findet
weil ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung ich
gebe noch mal schnell eben redstone ein
eventuell bekomme ich dann irgendwas mit
rats oder irgendwas angezeigt aber das
funktioniert auch nicht richtig also
keine ahnung wieso ich finde es ist eine
ganz gute idee ist allerdings noch sehr
sehr ausbau würdig ausbaufähig heißt es
glaube ich oder ich bin mir gerade
wieder überhaupt nicht sicher bei 208
dass ich glaube ist ausbaufähig freunde
wenn euch das video trotzdem gefallen
hat will ich mich immer wieder
schon freuen was kleines ich muss
unbedingt mein auge ausspielen oder
schon was damit passiert ist